AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA CALL THIS
ORGANIZATIONAL MEETING TO START-
SO POLICE WILL BE QUICKER BUT A
PRODUCTIVE MEETING THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR ATTENDANCE TODAY
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT
HOME WATER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. YOUR THE
HEARING ROOM ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE TO BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR
ELSEWHERE IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
FOR THE PUBLIC WE ASK YOU TO
PLEASE. MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND PLEASE BE SURE
TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE.
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL- WITH THAT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE AGENDA OF
THE BUSINESS ON FILE. WITH
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ONE. AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE ELECTION OF
A COMMITTEE CHAIR. REMINDED OF.
ARM IT'S SO GREAT TO BE
SPEAKING ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
AGAIN THIS WILL BE-UNCHARACTERISTICALLY BRIEF ARE
COMPARED TO MY HISTORY ON THE
FLOOR AND SO- IT'S WITH GREAT
PLEASURE THAT I MOVE THAT THE
COMMITTEE ELECT RUDY SALAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS ARCHER. ALL
RIGHT THAT'S BAD- MOTION BY.
OUR VICE CHAIR MISTER LAYERED.
INDIFFERENCE. TO YOUR
REPUTATION WE APPRECIATE THAT.
AND SECOND BY MR BORJAS- WITH
THAT WE WILL. YEP I HAVE MISTER
HERTZBERG PLEASE YEAH I JUST
WANT TO JOIN THE OF VICE CHAIR
AND- SEE WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO
STAND ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
AFTER A COUPLE OF DECADES AND
SPEAK HERE AND MAYBE STIR
THINGS UP AND MAYBE OFFER AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE MADE DOCTOR COULD WE
DO THAT BOB THIS I JUST I JUST
BECAUSE YOU HEART TO SEE WHAT
IT'S LIKE I WANT TO THAT MOTION
THIRD THAT MOTION. WILL TAKE
THE AS A AS A THIRD OF THE MOST
EVEN THOUGH WE ONLY NEED TO AND
SAY PREVIEW MISTER HERTZBERG
AYE WITH THAT'LL ME ASK THERE
ARE OTHERS MEMBERS I WISH BE
RECKONED HEARING AND SEE THE-
WE'RE GONNA GO TO MOVE TO A
CALL FIRST WE TAKE A VOTE- WITH
THAT- MISTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. PRESENT HERE
KILEY. PATTERSON RUBIO. SOUTH
PRESENT VOEPEL. WHAT. SENATOR
LAYER HERE. BAKER BORDERS.
GLAZER YEAH HERTZBERG YEAH.
LEYVA NIELSEN. RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUORUM THE QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED- WITH THAT WE WILL
RETURN TO BUSINESS ON THE
AGENDA WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND AND A THIRD- WITH THAT
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE ELECTION OF
COMMITTEE CHAIR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BORDER HARBATH. ONE OF
OUR BEST I KILEY. KILEY I
PATTERSON. PATTERSON I RUBIO.
SALAS HI SALAS HI VOEPEL. WHAT
THE HELL I WOULD. WOOD I CENTER
LAYERED ON LAYER I BAKER. BAKER
I BORDERS. OR JUST HI GLAZER.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I BELIEVE.
NIELSEN NIELSEN I. OKAY WITH
THAT THAT- GENDER ITEM- PASSES
WITHOUT WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
ORDER OF BUSINESS WHICH IS THE
ADOPTION OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO COMMITTEE
RULES I DO HAVE A MOTION. MOVED
BY MR BOARD JUST AND BY MR-
MISTER SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
WELL LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
JUST MEMBERS HEARING AND SEEING
NINE OF RESPECT CALDERON. SEVEN
SOUTH I SAW FIVE ONE OF OUR
BEST. BOERNER HORVATH HI KILEY.
K. I PATTERSON. BETTER I RUBIO.
VOEPEL TODAY MY- VOEPEL I WOULD.
WOULD HI CENTER LAY ON THERE
ARE BAKER. BAKER I FOR JUST.
FOR JUST I GLAZER. BIRDS
HERTZBERG HI LEYVA. NIELSEN
NIELSEN I. RIGHT THAT MOTION-
YOU FOR OUR FIRST-
ORGANIZATIONAL MEETING WE DO
HAVE A HEARING ON WEDNESDAY OCT
EDT FOR ALL THOSE THAT WISH TO
PARTICIPATE THAT WILL BEGIN AT
NINE THIRTY THAT'S IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE- IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING YOU GUYS
ARE WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ANOTHER TEN MINUTES TO
ALLOW THOSE MEMBERS THAT ARE
PRESENT NOW TO. JOIN ON THE
ROLE BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THANK
YOU.
HEY GUYS.
YEAH I. ALREADY
THERE OKAY WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
WITH THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE THE VOTES HAVE
BEEN MEMBERS THAT WERE- PRESENT.
AND THOSE THAT WERE NOT PRESENT
HAVE NOW ADDED ON TO THE
GENERAL BUSINESS ON AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER ONE THE ELECTION OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PASSES THIRTEEN
ZERO THE ADOPTION OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
COMMITTEE ROLES- PASSES
THIRTEEN ZERO WITH THAT WE WILL
CONCLUDE THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT. COMMITTEE HEARING THANK
YOU.